every Friday armed gangs forced these
young barbers to cut their hair on one
occasion they were caught up in a
shootout with police
the barbers closed their salon to escape
but lived in constant fear for their
lives that's why they decided to abandon
their homes and set off for the United
States
affion de el pelo epa's la verdad no
podía your perky I had to go to the gang
members to cut their hair but I couldn't
keep doing it out of fear I spoke about
it with my cousin and we decided to flee
we're afraid and just want to work in
peace as well as violence economic
problems are pushing people to migrate
almost three-quarters of all Hondurans
live in poverty according to some
estimates and more than half of the
self-employed there live in extreme
poverty we are searching for a better
homeland and opportunities to work we
want to move our families forward people
cannot bear the situation any longer the
crisis has been getting worse for years
it's happening because of the political
situation that's why people are fleeing
now they have nothing to eat I'm
supporting these migrants they're
fleeing because there's no work here
how can Donald Trump treat them as
murderers poverty in Honduras is on the
rise even though the government has
invested more in social programs
[Music]
[Applause]
this woman has tried seven times to
reach the United States only once did
she make it across the border only to be
deported but her situation is so
desperate that she plans to try again I
just can't go on like this
even if I could find a job I wouldn't
earn enough to support us the pay is
just too low I have three children who
need to be fed on her last journey she
was fleeing an abusive husband she took
her three children on the arduous trip
they suffered hunger and illness
eventually they were arrested by Mexican
authorities and deported I reported it
to the police and sought protection in
Mexico as I fled with my three children
he notified the migration authorities
and we spent eight months in detention
women suffer other types of violence
they are victims of domestic and sexual
abuse and are threatened by gangs who
try to recruit their children that's why
20 percent more women than men are
fleeing Honduras according to a
migration expert say less two years they
are pressured into prostitution or are
forced to live with people who are
involved in organized crime it's a
symptom of the vulnerability of women
migrants or refugees it's hard to draw a
line in a country where desperation and
danger go together for them escape seems
the only option